[MUSIC]
>> What does it take to change the world,
a breakthrough idea?
An unparalleled background
in technology and execution?
Rich, wealthy connections
to Stanford investors?
Over my ten years of experience in
consulting, in startup financing and
high tech in Silicone Valley,
I've become convinced that we
are profoundly mistaken in our
conventional wisdom in what it
takes to make breakthrough technology
succeed and to truly change the world.
It took me a moment of meeting the Google
ex co-founder face-to-face to realize
that the techniques that astrophysicists
and laser scientists are using
in Silicon Valley's most innovative
laboratories are simple, repeatable steps
that anyone with access to basic supplies
can start doing at home right away.
And even more excitingly, if we were
to really realize this as a society,
our communities, companies and
classrooms would never be the same.
My journey toward learning more
about innovation began when I was
a young girl in Topeka, Kansas.
When I was young, my greatest hope for
the future of technology would be that
we would invent a better remote control.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And my greatest hope for
government was that we'd find
a way to keep the streets swept,
particularly in the snow while minimizing
taxes for my dad's small business.
Growing up in Kansas, I never imagined
that a non-engineer could work for
a company like Google.
But in 2010, I found out.
In fact, they could.
And after a year of getting my ducks
in a row, I applied for Google and
I landed my first job there.
Very quickly into my time at Google,
I got the opportunity to help build tech
support teams, to help make Gmail and
other Google apps usable by businesses
large and small around the world.
We started off trying to train people from
many cultures how to answer a simple tech
question on the phone and resolve it, so
the customer could move on with their day.
But over time we started to realize
that this awesome staff we built
weren't just tech support agents.
In fact, they were very skillful, very
creative humans who could do a lot more
for the humans on the other side of
the phone than we had originally thought.
At first, we started small.
Helping new customers go from fixing an
early problem to anticipating what might
happen next.
Then if someone called with one question,
we try and help figure out what was
actually going on that they were
trying to use technology to solve.
And then finally, we realized that if
we were really effective at helping our
customers on the phone,
we could help them bring technology
to bear on their workforce and
their company to power present and
future goals that they found important.
The most amazing learning for me in this
process was actually that innovation
doesn't have to happen only for
teams that are developing software.
In fact, when you can teach people to
innovate whose work involves other people,
amazing things can happen and
things can transform
with the smallest intervention
is one interaction on the phone.
After Alexis Google, it wasn't long
before I found myself in a very strange
classroom in an innovation mansion on the
border of Alamo Square in San Francisco.
I stepped through the beautiful entryway,
looked at the grand staircase coming down
from above and followed red rope lights
into a mysterious basement that turned
out to be a very curious place indeed.
Here Tom Chi, a Co-Founder of Google X
was unveiling the methods that
Google X's engineers had used to
develop breakthrough technologies
that put the Internet
on floating balloons.
I was very excited and I was especially
enthusiastic, because the one thing our
team hadn't figured out how to do was to
solve a bottleneck and engineering talent.
Basically, how did we get
more technical skills and
technical people to help bring our
customer insights into real opportunities,
and tools for our customers.
As Tom began to share,
he talked about how a lot of the world's
wealth runs through its largest companies,
but companies don't actually develop
all of the technology that they create.
And whether they develop it or not, they
tend to own the patents for 20 more years.
What I started to realize is we couldn't
just trust that the world's big companies
would have a handle on
the innovation that we really need
to solve the problems we want
to see solved in our lifetime.
Instead, it was going to take a lot of
people working together really quickly in
order to tackle problems on
the scale of climate change and
we were going to need to
get started right away.
As Tom shared the method,
I started to become astonished.
Because what I imagined would be a highly
math intensive engineering specific
discipline really boiled down to three
steps that Google access engineers
use over and over, and over to reduce
uncertainty, and bring the reality.
Bring the present in the future
into present reality.
Step one, start with a skit.
Step two,
build something basic using pretty
accessible kindergarten level supplies.
And step three, change as you go.
Again and again,
they repeated this process.
And in the room, we use post-its and
scissors to do the same thing.
Start with a skit.
Build something basic.
Change as you go.
Start with a skit.
Build something basic.
Change as you go.
The more we repeated this process,
the more it started to sink in.
It wasn't just my team at Google that
had had everything we needed to move
forward on building technology in
our corporate context, but actually
the classrooms I had grown up in in
Kansas had everything we needed then too.
I was infuriated.
I'm not sure where got the message
that in order to create the future,
I needed access to the best science and
technology labs and
teachers who had 20 years of
experience in data science.
But at this point, I started to realize
that if we all truly believe in this
potential, a lot could change and
a lot more people could be
involved in directing that change.
The next stage in my career was
a three-year stint testing my hypothesis
that this was a basic process
that anybody could learn.
I taught people from 50 organizations
from the US Department of Labor
to Girl Scouts at a science and tech camp.
I taught corporate, entrepreneurial and
nonprofit sector leaders from Norway
to Vietnam and including the American
Midwest and the biggest insight I
had from that journey was a workshop I
taught to undergrads in Central Iowa.
The workshop began and everyone started,
and very quickly as I do.
I said, let's going.
Time to build, right?
Yehey, and this young woman named Chelsea
looked up at me and said, I can't do it.
I can't go forward and I said, why not?
She looks at me and said,
you're asking me to create and
no ones ever even told
me I can be creative
That's when I realized that there
are thousands of creators besides my
original self who don't even
realize that we can create.
And in fact, we are creating all the time.
But our own lack of awareness that,
that's what we're already up to and
it's absolutely us who can do it
holds us back from really making
headway on the things
we care about the most.
What I learned over the course of
this journey is that imagination and
invention aren't hyperspecific
technologies that no one can use.
It's that actually,
it's more like imagination is a muscle.
It's a process that anybody can pickup
that you can exercise and develop.
And by practicing in this method,
you can begin to make real progress
on the things you care about and
your community cares about the most and
you can empower your workforce and
your economy to do exactly the same.
If we really live like
imagination as a muscle,
you all can make a huge difference,
even in the rest of this week.
Maybe you would start by looking around
you for people with wild ideas who
really could just grab a piece of scrap
paper and start to draw what the wireframe
interface would look like rather than
applying to another accelerator.
Or worse yet,
quitting if they don't get in.
You could look around at the groups,
the communities and
the workforces that you are a part of for
places where actually a lot more is
possible than humans just
doing routine activities.
And if you did, you might find out
that the unemployment graph flipped.
Starts to look like
capacity to innovate and
you could put your ear to the ground for
some innovators, either likely or
unlikely who might not yet have been told
that, in fact, they too can be creative.
Returning to your routine today, I invite
you to start this process by keeping
an open mind for maybe a project that you
haven't been able to move forward yet.
Is there something that you can just
put on a rough sheet of paper and
hand to a friend to test?
If you did, I think you might discover
that you are far more inventive,
even very rapidly than
you ever dared to think.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]